we've gone off to a very quiet start  here no they're not they haven't got the  pitchforks out now this is all a bit of  tap dancing Daniel seems a little  nervous even hiding in his shirt well  the thing is though you know it is a  very quiet position but uh Daniel does  Have To Tread accurately because the  long game is brewing you know it's that  advantage that we talked about you know  it's building and the more pieces that  get traded off the more things that  Dania doesn't do then uh the more  pressing this extra Pawn in the middle  will be so I I think he will be feeling  nervous you know that's the thing with  chess you know it's not just you know  swords drawn and swords meets in the  middle of the board you know sometimes  you have the long game and you have all  this nervous tension and yeah he doesn't  look comfortable meanwhile